The Joe Rogan Experience was there the
fear that you entering into professional
tournaments would knock your gambling
these people would know that you by this
time people everyone knew I mean you
know it didn't take long before a few
few trips I went by my middle name yeah
because there were magazines that you
know you could see what's going on
around the country right you just might
not get a picture or a video of it or
whatever so you start to hear names you
know so like first time I went to
California
uh I did that actually and you know it
worked out nice so what did you do you
just use a different name well it's a
funny story and I think he can laugh
about it now but you know Marcus shamott
is right from Sweden so
so there was a guy that was staking him
and a lot of other great players and and
he was big action the guy was
and I knew Marcus was out there and so
I'm in hard times
I think I told you about this the other
day with Keith but the only two people
in the hard times that knew me all right
uh was Keith and Jose perika all right
so everyone else didn't know who I was
so Marcus Shaman is standing next to two
other guys that I know play but won't
play kind of thing
so I go up and I ask those two guys I
was like you know one of y'all want to
play some you know 50 100 sets of nine
ball you know knowing
Marcus is gonna just jump right on me
you know what I mean like he's right
next to him so long story short that
happened
and uh but I introduced myself as Tyler
my middle name you know like I just did
you know so we start playing he beats me
a set for a hundred playing even I quit
he offers me the eight
beats me a set for 200 I quit
now he offers me the seven
so now his stakehorse starts coming over
near me because Marcus is just stealing
this little four or five hundred ain't
got nothing to do with the stakeholder
you know what I mean it's just like
pocket money
so now his steak horse comes over and
he's kind of interested in the game and
he says he'll give you the seven but you
gotta bet you know everything you got
I got like 25 or 30 000 on me you
wouldn't know it but I do you know so I
can't pull out 25 or 30 000 they're
gonna know something's up
so me and my buddy we just talked for a
second so we ended up pulling out like 4
500.
so we play for a little bit
and uh
now we're playing Seven ahead we were
playing a race to seven for the 100 and
200 right
so now he thinks he's stealing because I
mean the way I played in the other two
sets you know what I'm saying so he just
comes out like gangbusters he's got me
like four games down I'm talking my
buddy I'm like man this is sick we're
gonna get beat in this spot right here
I'm getting the seven you know
so finally I get a shot and I start to
run out now I'm starting to run out and
so his stay course is there and he says
man ain't this something you know what I
mean he says uh we thought we were
stealing it looks it looks real bad now
so so I beat him that set
so now at hard times you've been there
right in L.A yeah Bellflower yeah so
they got the players side right with the
tight tables and they got the looser
tables well he had me on the looser
tables thinking you know I'm just a
sucker you know
so he says uh the state course says
double the BET and we'll give you the
eight on the tight tables
right so this is like really good for me
you know now I'm getting a spot on even
a tougher table so I beat him that set
but during that second set
a friend of mine had built me a queue
and send it out to the guy that ran the
tournaments in LA right
so I'm going by Tyler and this guy walks
up and he says
real loud he says are you Jeremy Jones
oh no he says if you are I got a cue for
you you know and I was like no I ain't
there because I'm in the middle of this
13 uh nine thousand dollar set plan you
know so I said no I ain't Jeremy Jones
you know and I just sent him on his way
and then the next day when I came in
Mark knew who I was and you know
everyone spilled the beans kind of thing
yeah and I had to go tell the guy all
right that's my cue and everything so it
was mad at you no no not at all he
understood it's kind of like a funny
story around there now I think but
Marcus was mad at me for a little while
yeah that's why I was asking oh yeah
because he was European you know and it
was just kind of like you know if
someone got me like that you know I'm
gonna it's gonna sting but it's gonna be
more like all right touche kind of thing
you know what I'm saying later on you
know we're gonna laugh about it and
stuff but it took it's almost like if
you first beat Efren he walks by you but
he don't say much to you for about a
month or two really oh yeah he's gonna
let that wear off a little bit but took
Mark is probably about a decade before
it was bad so when when he beat you the
first two sets even were you
were you hustling a little well I might
not have put forth my best effort but he
played real good you know what I mean he
was all right let me pick up this thing
honestly trying to set something up well
I thought I you know I'm definitely not
trying to win for 200. you know what I
mean like his steak horse who now is
actually after that trip became a real
good friend of mine you know at that
time he was known you could beat him out
of you know 40 and 50 you know a
thousand right so you're not going to
start off doing anything like that for
200 or so so when you first start
playing you play good but you're not
really bearing down right right so
you're showing them that you can play a
little but you might miss some shots
that plus I want to see him play right
you know I heard the name I kind of
wanted to really see because eventually
to beat him out of the real money is
going to be playing even right you know
what I mean because he's another great
player so that eventually was going to
happen but Mark is into having to leave
the country for his Visa got shortened
up or something like that he actually
ended up leaving the next day
but I stuck around for about a month in
these other countries is there a lot of
gambling going on obviously in the
Philippines there is but is there a lot
of gambling going on in these other
countries where all these players are
emerging the sum of Asia for sure
um southeast Asia especially I think you
know Thailand like you said Philippines
Indonesia um
you're up here and there not a whole lot
not a whole lot at all and I I think
it's more of the stakehorse kind of
situation it's just not the mentality
you know there's not a state course you
know people aren't just thinking oh let
me go put somebody else in action for
thousands of dollars you know it's just
not your everyday thing one of the fun
parts of American pool culture the steak
horses oh absolutely they're some of the
biggest characters yes wild crazy people
with tons of money yeah and how they got
it yeah
yeah and uh they're interested in
gambling on pool
yeah I've been paid in uh buried money
quite a few times really oh yeah oh yeah
it stinks it stinks usually oh yeah not
nice wow the whole car stunk yeah
really oh yeah real bad do you think
there's like bodies next to the I don't
think so why don't it smell just mildew
and yeah I think so yeah I'm
talking about yeah I think this has been
there a long time 30 to 30 years yeah
there was a guy one time we were in
South Carolina is another place that uh
are frequented in the Summers especially
because we gambled a golf but um this
guy Frank and he's a great great guy and
he was the coming in overalls didn't
know he had a penny but he staked a lot
of players and he did a lot for the pool
community so he comes in one morning
because we'd all meet at the pool room
about 10 a.m and we'd all make a golf
game then we'd go out to the golf course
Gamo golf come back to the pool room and
make pool games right it was it was
awesome I mean the whole summer was like
this
so as Frank comes in one morning
and uh
he looked real upset and he never looked
upset always happy
even if he lost he is happy and so I
said Frank what's wrong you okay
I'll come out my back door and I saw one
of my bushes dug up today so
one of his sons that is kind of was you
know a little detached at times from the
family for one reason or another he let
us stay there and he said he knew it
right it was a thirty thousand dollar
Bush oh yeah yeah yeah and so he took it
like a grain of salt he was more
disappoint it was kind of like a
disappointed father kind of thing more
than upset he had plenty of money you
know yeah so but it's amazing what
people do with their money oh there I
can't tell you probably maybe the
craziest I'll tell you later on the
craziest ones on there but uh
uh let's see uh so so so one time I was
a tournament in uh Mississippian
to get on with this I won the tournament
uh tough tournament Johnny Archer all
the great players and his bar tables so
I won like 8 000.
so by the time I won the tournament I
think I was about 25 000 losers in the
casino okay like terrible trip I mean I
wasn't even trying you remember Tony
Ellen yes so he was 20 minutes late to
get a steak dinner at the Horseshoe it
cost me about 12 000. I went down there
said let me just let me just pitch 300
you know and they just pounded me right
so
I got the tournament money after winning
it was 8 000.
went straight to the cage and cashed it
went straight to the blackjack
yeah I had it about 10 minutes so the 8
000 was gone
and so this guy that was playing there
his name was Frank seals and he was a
legendary steak horse
and they used to take CJ when he was a
kid and a lot of players throughout the
years and he said hey if you're ever
bored you want to come up to Morristown
Tennessee I got a kid I'll let you play
if you still want to play you know I
like the way you gamble is what he said
he watched me play Blackjack blow all my
money right yeah so
yeah so I had yeah I told him this one I
said you ain't dealing with me with no
Blackjack up there if I go up there so
anyways I go up there
so he's got this guy Mark Owens was his
name good player and uh real high gear
maybe not the most steady player but
real high gear
so we're playing we start out playing
races to 9 or 10 or something for a
thousand so long story short I got him
10 000 loser okay
and it's because we raised it and
whatnot and uh so now the whole town
this is a small town okay just up in the
northeast corner of Tennessee so the
whole town starts coming in and this is
their hero
so my buddy starts taking bets on the
side you know
so now we I got him ten thousand loser
and he says we want to play a set for 10
000. this is what Frank says the the
steak horse he says but we need to call
eight you know what the call is of
course right so uh so I said okay yeah
so we're gonna race the race to 15. so
we're betting about 10 000 on the side
okay so we're playing a set for like 20.
all right because my buddy's got a list
of bets this long with all the town
people you know what I mean yeah so
it's nine to eight me instead of playing
safe on the eight I try to jack up off
the end Rail and stab it in and draw my
ball you know what I mean and I Bobble
it he makes it he breaks and runs five
racks he's up 14-9
so now he breaks going to 15.
and the 4 9 is wired over the spot he
makes an incredible shot on the one he's
got the three down the rail and he's
just got a cupcake on the 4-9
so I turned my buddy and I said man we
ain't got but like 8 000 left you know
because we're a winner we start off a
thousand a set I said we can't lower the
bet you can't do that then they know
you're short
you know what I'm saying yeah yeah so
I'm like what are we going to do you
know we get more money tomorrow and
whatever right
so the pool tables here
right
he's shooting at this corner
now Frank is the only guy he's sitting
right here on a stool chair right like a
little school chair everyone else is way
back over here besides me and my buddies
over here right all the people watching
so he knocks a three and Mark does and
he comes down he was kind of one of
those guys that would fire the nine in
you know what I'm saying you've seen
them
he rifles this four nine he could have
just tapped it and it would have rolled
right in the corner this ball went down
and swirled around in the pocket
jumped almost all the way back out to
the spot that's how far it went oh my
God yeah all the money's on the light
right
so Frank he knows about pulling the
balls aimed directly at Frank so as soon
as he hits it he knows it's in
so Frank starts to get up and get the
money I said oh Frank I said The Nine's
on the table you know Frank's like 75
years old he's got glasses
so I said the knives on the table he
says oh I'm sorry you know like he
didn't realize it didn't go in well it
did go in it just came back out
yeah never pocketed another ball the
whole set I played safe on that first
shot I broke a ram played save broke
around beat him 15-14 right wow yeah so
now the kid he quits and he's he's
literally crying out on the stairs okay
so Frank says come back the next day
we'll play you some more so we come back
the next day we start out playing like
for 3 500 races to 11. so I beat him
three sets so he says hey he's going to
take a break he said he'll play some
more in a minute I'm like sweet man this
is good good action you know
so Frank's sitting in this chair right
here
and the kids practicing a little bit and
he hits a ball in that same pocket it
jumps the pocket hits Frank dead in the
eye right his glasses and blood's going
everywhere I mean Jesus Christ oh yeah
yeah it was ironically crazy right so we
end up having to quit and we never end
up playing again
so the same pocket that kind of saved me
the day before right kind of got them
the next day and we ended up never
playing yeah
funny story I'm kind of shitty table is
that it was a gold crown but it had a
replacement Pockets you know the big
black ones that go in they're kind of
bulky they kind of move around a little
bit shitty job yeah yeah it's old school
pool hall oh man yeah that Frankie was
something else so that he I'm playing
right and he pulls up his overall
and uh I see a gunshot wound in his leg
I said dang Frank you got shot
he said yeah my wife shot me about 10
years ago I said man you mean your
ex-wife don't you he says no he says I'm
still with her right I said damn
about three months later she killed him
after I played yeah same lady that shot
her shot 10 months before
you shot him dead dead
did I think she did six months in a
mental place and then she's out oh my
God yeah six months six months that was
it yeah that's it she'd shot him twice
[Music]
more I think it was like five of them in
the church yeah yeah
sure I was telling you about that buried
money yeah Frank gave me some of that
buried I think he was kind of like a
numbers guy you know how they run the
lottery out in the country on their own
and stuff yeah I think he did like stuff
like that so